[Music]
[Applause]
Bill Shakin L.A Times National Baseball
columnist joining us and uh trying to
look at the show hey uttani situation
with a variety of angles we got two
weeks to go for the trade deadline let
me look at the business side of this
bill
can the Angels afford to not resign Tony
I think the Angels would be delighted to
resigni uh the question is were there
shohei Otani would be delighted to
resign with the angels and I know
there's a concern oh well the Angels
offer him a deal
you can say a lot of things about Artie
Moreno the Angel's owner but you can't
say that he doesn't spend the money in
fact the guy with the largest contract
in major league baseball right now is
Mike Trout who was given that contract
by Artie Moreno so I have no doubt Artie
Moreno will make them a good offer I
think the question is does shohei want
to stay and no one really knows the
answer to that right now
but can the Angels afford to let ohtani
go to free agency
as opposed to a trade you man yeah
yeah I mean I think part of what has
been lost in all the trade discussions
is the way Artie Marino operates his
team
and again you can say what you want
about them because the Angels haven't
won with trout and Otani that's
certainly you know look scoreboard
bottom line but
ultimately
Artie Moreno isn't an owner that says
you know what we're going to rebuild for
a few years come back and see us in five
years
um I'm gonna make a lot of profits in
the meantime he puts money into the team
sometimes it works out sometimes it
doesn't but the idea of an Artie Moreno
is going to blow up the Angels is just
not going to happen so if you're in a
situation like you're in with Otani
you're not looking for somebody's five
best prospects who are all in single a
and double A that's not going to work
because Mike Trout's still here so
You're Gonna Want guys that can help the
major league team next year maybe not
all of them but most of them and if
you're on the other side of that
equation and your contending team
that you want Otani to put you over the
top this year
the guys you would trade to the angels
you're going to need maybe not all of
them but certainly some of them and I
think that really complicates any trade
so you think when all said and done
ohtani goes to free agency
but is can somebody uh outspend Artie
Moreno in this situation or will
somebody else spend Artie Moreno
well I'm sure somebody can Artie Moreno
is a single gentleman uh the Dodgers for
example were bought with money from
insurance funds so yeah I mean there's
going to be a competitive market uh the
Giants or for example if you go to a
Giants game remember they've spent the
last few years trying to buy a superstar
they tried Bryce Harper didn't work they
tried Aaron judge it didn't work they
tried Carlos Correa their doctor saved
them from that so they've got the money
and if you go to a Giants game and you
look behind right field there's a whole
Urban Village going up there that's
money that's all going in the Giants
pockets they can outbid anybody
certainly the Yankees can outbid anybody
Stevie Cohen by himself can outbid
anybody there'll be plenty of
competition but I don't think it's going
to be a situation of artist Moreno runs
away from it how do you monetize ohtani
if you're the angels and you have him
through his first three years when he
can't even get to arbitration and then
his arbitration years it's really easy
he's made the Angels a ton of money if
you ever watch an Angel game on TV the
Billboard's behind on plate behind the
batter they're all in Japanese The
Outfield signs are in Japanese many of
the stadium giveaways the t-shirts and
the pillows and the hats feature Otani
Japanese companies sponsor those that
has added up in the past to about 10 or
15 million dollars a year
so if she always make it a million
dollars you're doing great
um if show is making 50 or 60 million
dollars a year that's not going to do it
I mean you will sell more tickets and
certainly you will be able to sell some
merchandise but you know most
merchandise if it's not sold outside the
stadium that's shared Revenue among
teams uh International broadcast revenue
is shared Revenue okay so if you're
signing showing atani you're doing it
because it's going to make your team
better but the idea that he's going to
pay for himself is not going to happen
Bill Shakin the LA Times National
Baseball columnist joining us the A's
um is there any chance that they stay in
Oakland
I would say there's a very small chance
um it's a little bit better chance than
the A's making the playoffs this year
but not that much better
um basically baseball was kind of tired
of waiting and who's ever at fault in
the situation the A's their various
owners various governments not only in
Oakland because the A's have tried to
move around the Bay Area mostly the
Giants from blocking the A's from moving
to San Jose which was the obvious answer
yeah the the problem now is that the A's
went to Vegas they got close to 400
million dollars in Public Funding the
Bill's already signed into law there was
more accomplished in Vegas in you know
two weeks my Major League Baseball's
accounting than there was in 20 years of
looking for a stadium in Oakland
now what's happened in Las Vegas is that
some people as you can imagine are very
upset about this why are we giving money
to an out-of-state billionaire is a
powerful campaign pitch right so the
teachers union in the state of Nevada
would like to take that campaign pitch
and put it on the ballot whether they
can get to that point or not we don't
know it's very expensive to get
something onto a ballot because you need
to collect a lot of signatures it would
of course be even more expensive for the
campaign and there are a lot of unions
lining up in favor of this project
certainly the construction unions that
would build a stadium the most powerful
Union in Las Vegas is the one that
represents the folks that would work at
the stadium because as everyone knows
there's kind of a large hospitality
industry in Las Vegas they run the town
so unless something happens either in a
court if that 380 million dollars in
Public Funding is challenged and somehow
thrown out or unless there's a thing on
the ballot I think it's a done deal and
I think it's a very small chance that it
doesn't get to that point I think the
A's are gone I know we uh we focus on
Otani and rightfully so with the trade
deadline can you see any other big names
possibly moved
um you certainly can I mean it's not you
know any great surprise this time of
year you look at the the teams that
maybe are not doing so well and try to
figure out who their best players are so
for example you know Marcus strowman
from the Cubs is having a great year uh
Cody Bellinger from the Cubs is having a
pretty good year those are name players
that people have heard of and have done
pretty well you know maybe guys that you
haven't heard of as much you know at
Dylan cease with the White Sox for
example or Dylan Carlson with the
Cardinals again these are teams that uh
you know are not doing so well and you
know from an L.A point of view uh their
high school teammates both on the market
Lucas giolito from the White Sox Jack
Flaherty from the Cardinals played high
school ball together and they could both
be on the move and certainly their
Hometown teams both of them are looking
for starting pitching
uh Rob Manfred uh looks like he's gonna
be uh voted for re-election
um I'm guessing based off this year it
has is baseball having a a great year
yeah you know everybody said oh
baseball's dead right we've heard that
for how many years and yet in the First
full year after the pandemic last year
coming off a lockout that was imposed by
the owners
the owners made more Revenue last year
than they ever had it's going to be more
this year attendance is up
um Bud selig once said when he was
commissioner my job is to get the
owner's asset values to rise and Rob
hasn't put it quite that plainly but the
owners are his bosses the owners are
happy the owners don't mind when Rob Van
Fred takes a hit or two because it saves
them from doing it I think everything's
fine that I don't think he'll have any
issue winning reelection Bill good to
talk to you thanks for joining us all
right take care bill Shakin L.A Times
National Baseball columnist it sounds
like shohei uttani you go to free agency
but is somebody going to
well there's always one somebody gets
squirrely you got 12 days there but
there really hasn't been much that's
leaked out